[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben kennt ihr das ihr sollt
irgendwas zu mittag kochen oder besuch
kündigt sich an und ihr braucht irgend
etwas leckeres zu essen und hab mal
wieder keine ahnung was wir kochen
sollte dann habe ich hier die perfekte
idee für euch es gibt leckere
hähnchenbrustfilets mit gemüse
kichererbsen und einer fettarmen tomaten
sahnesoße damit ihr auch ohne schlechtes
gewissen schlemmen könnt und das ganze
sehr wie ich auf würzigem couscous
reiche dazu noch naturjoghurt und
schnittlauch wie immer ist das rezept
sehr unkompliziert und einfach
nachzumachen und das gute ist wir
benötigen keine exotischen zutaten jetzt
starten wir zuallererst mit der
hauptspeise
dafür benötigen wir eine hühnchenbrust
die habe ich in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten etwas öl curry und edel
süßes paprikapulver honig ein paar
möhren bereits vorgekochte kichererbsen
außerdem eine knoblauchzehe fein
gehackte zwiebeln ein wenig tomatenmark
und sana dann nehme ich gerne die fed
reduzierte variante und desweiteren
benötigen wir gemüsebrühe und sojasauce
als allererstes habe ich das öl in einer
beschichteten pfanne erhitzt und gebe
dort die fein gehackten zwiebeln mit
hinein
nachdem die zwiebeln glasig gedünstet
wurden kommt die knoblauchzehe mit
hinein und wird dann noch für ein paar
sekunden mit gedünstet
anschließend geben wir die hähnchenbrust
filetstückchen mit dazu und braten sie
von allen seiten gut an
nach ein paar minuten gebe ich dann die
sojasauce mit hinzu und verrühren das
ganze miteinander
übrigens schreibe ich euch die genauen
mengenangaben immer unten in die infobox
an dieser stelle gebe ich noch den honig
mit hinzu und ich empfehle euch wirklich
den honig mit rein zu machen auch wenn
ihr gar keine honig fans seid vielleicht
nimmt das mal mit rein und ihr werdet
auf jeden fall den kleinen aber feinen
unterschied merken
[Musik]
an der stelle gebe ich noch das
tomatenmark mit hinzu und verrührt das
auch gut miteinander bis sich das ganze
vermengt hat ihr könnt natürlich auch
anschließend noch passierte tomaten mit
reinnehmen jedoch mag ich es nicht wenn
die saucen extrem tomaten lastig
schmecken also schaut da einfach nach
eurem geschmack und dann geht es auch
schon weiter mit den möhren und mit den
küche erbsen
nachdem die also auch im topf gelandet
sind löschen wir das ganze mit der
gemüsebrühe und anschließend mit der
sahne ab
[Musik]
die fed reduzierte variante nicht
bevorzugt der kann hier an der stelle
auch einen becher schlagsahne mit hinein
geben
[Musik]
jetzt geben wir noch die zwei gewürze
mit hinzu und an der stelle brauchte
auch gar kein salz mehr mit hin zu geben
denn wir haben ja schon die salzige
sojasauce und noch die gemüsebrühe das
reicht vollkommen
nun lasse ich das ganze 15 minuten lang
köcheln und zwar ohne decke damit die
soße ein wenig eindecken kann
und so sieht das endergebnis aus nach 15
minuten
ich zeige euch hier nochmal die
flüssigkeit falls ihr so schon zufrieden
seid damit dann ist das ganze jetzt
schon fertig ich möchte das allerdings
ein klein wenig selbiger und
dickflüssiger und habe jetzt hier ein
gemisch aus wasser und mehl und gibt das
jetzt noch mal mit in den topf lass das
ganze kurz aufkochen und dann habe ich
eine ganz klein wenig dickflüssigere
konsistenz
für die leckere beilage benötigen wir in
stand couscous ein wenig wasser außerdem
öl da könnt ihr olivenöl oder auch
neutrales öl nehmen außerdem noch butter
an gewürzen benötigen wir kurkuma salz
und pfeffer und eine knoblauchzehe in
meinen heißen topf habe ich das öl
hineingegeben dünnste darin die
knoblauchzehe an gebe dann nach ein paar
sekunden schon die gewürze mit hinzu
frühere das ganz kurz um und dann wird
das ganze mit dem wasser abgelöscht und
ein mal aufgekocht
[Musik]
anschließend wird der herd ausgeschaltet
dann geben wir den couscous mit hinein
rühren ihnen ganz kurz um damit er auch
vollständig mit dem wasser bedeckt ist
anschließend gebe ich den deckel darauf
und lasse das ganze drei minuten lang
ziehen
so ist der kuss kuss auch schon gar und
sofort servieren bereit ich gebe immer
gerne noch ein stück butter mit hinzu
damit ihr ein wenig weicher und fluch
engagiert mit dem zwei gabeln locker ich
das gleichzeitig noch ein wenig auf und
die butter schmilzt auch schon in der
hitze des kurses am topfboden solltet
ihr natürlich ein wenig aufpassen dann
nehme ich am liebsten meinen holz
kochlöffel
und was beim fertigen gericht nicht
fehlen darf ist natürlich joghurt ich
habe hier fällt am naturjoghurt ein
wenig getrocknete minze außerdem noch
salz und pfeffer und eine knoblauchzehe
und depression direkt in den joghurt
hinein gebe anschließend die gewürze mit
hinzu und dann wird das schön verrührt
bis ich alles miteinander verbunden hat
[Musik]
und so sieht das ganze angerichtet aus
ich finde die farben sehen wunderschön
aus die geschmackskomponenten passen
wunderbar zusammen
und falls ihr das ganze mal nach macht
dann hinterlasst mir doch gerne feedback
in den kommentaren
falls ihr kein video mehr verpassen
möchte dann hinterlasst mir doch gerne
ein abo darüber würde ich mich sehr
freuen
und ich sag bis zum nächsten mal auf
richtiges kitchen tschüss
[Musik]